and here's the finished product I'll
open up dev tools and take a look inside
the style tag you can see that I just
simply did exactly what you learned a
minute ago only this time I'm dividing
by three instead of two let's break this
down
I set a margin rate of ten pixels so
that each image has a margin to the
right of it of ten pixels and I set the
last of type selector on the image to
margin right zero this makes sure that
there's no margin after the last one
then to calculate the width I simply
took the whole viewport 100% subtracted
the 20 pixels taken up by the two
margins and divided by three calc is
really awesome I hope you realize just
how awesome this is you're mixing and
matching units and it's giving you
something useful make sure you take
advantage of calc whenever you can